[Music]
and daddy's girls new ah submitted by
blackjack still live dads are now taking
classes on age-appropriate makeup in
order to be more involved and born with
their young daughters how wonderful my
daughter April wear makeup ever just
kidding okay but what if it's like her
prom or something I do whatever the [ __ ]
she wants she just won't be wearing
makeup until she is in high school at
school
I think that's fine I was like yo you
get lessons from your mom starting
junior high but you ain't go where that
[ __ ] at school all the time if you are
the first make fun of you for it [ __ ]
those [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] them up don't
worry about that [ __ ] what about can she
do like the eyebrows or you wanted to be
bushy eyebrow and think I look like cat
my mom did it with me because it was
very age-appropriate but at that time it
was false we got [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah
uh so I couldn't shave my legs and I
couldn't pluck anything until I was in
high school no definitely much hope you
didn't play soccer with a bushy ass
[ __ ] legs what is what she asked legs
do though doesn't do [ __ ]
there's people away that's exactly what
my mom wanted to do God anyway I feel
what a girl horny I like girls huh I
said I saw what I got horny I like girls
yeah cuz you're not looking at them
naked I think you're in junior high dude
you're just looking at their face
because I don't need this class to teach
me about makeup I grew up in abuse
Plaistow yeah I mean I know what's up
but at the end I know they wrote in the
article they're like except for David
okay thank you yes mitosis I just don't
wanna my kid could be so dependent or
just like just women around me and just
be so dependent on makeup to define what
their beauty is you know I mean that
should be something that you control
like you're already beautiful as is but
I don't want the girl done oh god I
can't walk out with that type of share
I'll not do this I'm ugly as girls out
there in his world dude and the makeup
is like their key to success like
they're going places how do you feel
about make sure
don't wear any where any yeah my mom
said it cuz I don't be a big girl and
she always just like no you're really
nice Kim I mean it looks nice from the
fall if you up close I'll shut up it's
still nice we'll be talking about this
is your wife right Taman is going away
exactly
I didn't go up wearing it out if you
want and be [ __ ] up yeah I would okay
[ __ ] I was like that's true when y'all
were in Hawaii I noticed it looked like
y'all like we're kind of thick and like
pale right and I was like what no [ __ ]
no disrespect I'm just like observe go
for I think the same thing when I look
in the mirror and have no makeup on like
dude I look at this end of the time
y'all were glowing you know it's
different every turn oh you feel like
whether you look at the grieving you
know it's that la face it is flat face
yeah yeah where I like to try any makeup
on or anything ah actually I did so we
have like a like a prom I guess kind of
in high school and I work too like a
year 11 mu 12 formal I was like the only
time it was literally just like a little
bit of mascara and that kind of stuff
and I remember one time I let my friend
you like foundation the whole shebang
and it looks white because I'm tans
compared to most people I don't look it
but in back home I'm usually like the
more tan one because there's like a lot
of Greeks and Italians and a little bit
lighter skinned and my friend try to use
her makeup on my face and I was like
white I look like I don't know Michael
Jackson proof surgery up top and then
Michael Jackson pre-surgery down the
bottom it looks good and so on you're
lucky I can never again never again but
but you're the [ __ ] a class - [ __ ]
huh pillage it lots of them work so
there's a beauty bar in New York I don't
feel pretty wearing makeup by the way
when we did makeup it makes me feel
gross like it's sticky it's
uncomfortable the [ __ ] eye eyelashes
way my eyes down and it's so like I need
my muscles doing rubber when we have the
eyelash I couldn't keep my eyes open
I'm so heavy Vicki everything is all
sticky and powdery and like it feels
nasty
you're right I do like it when I shave
though that's when I feel I feel clean
my facial has been finally coming out
five five little chin what I have to
shave every like two three days three
days now though before it was like I saw
two weeks tear the struggle I just did
this yes yeah yeah you're using your
razor a common going go man it's nice
you've been wanting your [ __ ] hair to
come out it does now it's annoying
no because it's be ready he likes
complaining no because it's annoying for
me because because it's like six here to
here it looks [ __ ] stupid you know
too babe and then what's so [ __ ] dumb
I'd be okay with it
yeah lays it off I know I should huh
just fix up yeah what is the pay the
full price phone okay you watch it
there's like what's that on your face
like what she goes oh you're not like
facial I'm coming up it's like for
departed with this chest he has like
four little hairs coming up I'll put
those up yeah please I just have it all
my nipple just ringing around it looks
like a [ __ ] weed whackers right
around my nipple I just got to shave
just that part best VI that's the asian
fingers Asian people we don't have to
have no chest they're just the
ring-around-the-rosie that's it rosy
nipple yeah so there's a beauty bar in
New York in the Upper East Side that are
offering these classes to dead so they
can learn how to do age-appropriate
makeup on their daughters so here's some
photos music some service that is
utterly confused the [ __ ] is my
pretending like it's like it's like when
your smart friends tries to break some
[ __ ] equation down and you don't want
to sound stupid so you're just like hmm
tested [ __ ] your pic and the other one
we are learning like certain techniques
on how to do makeup on their daughters
because they're saying like some of
these dads you know they're single dads
or widowed dad or gay dads or happily
married dads but they're the mountain to
travel a lot so they need to learn how
to just want to bond in a different way
dude that takes you pedantic
it's literally not
yeah it's [ __ ] annoying literally
that yeah because they're saying like
sometimes like some of these dads are
like you know it's a Bar Mitzvah season
and like we have so many permits us to
go to but my daughter you know I'm not
like always very the mother Yukon and so
it's like how am I gonna help my
daughter get ready zone you know what
you know what the funny thing is though
I think makeup is like a skill set that
you build over time because you're doing
it on like a daily yeah you know it's
something that you're constantly doing
right so you're developing this skill
set so as mothers like they're doing it
on themselves on her friends or whatever
so they can teach this skill right that
Daddy does it once he's gonna [ __ ] it up
my daddy's a painter or an artist of the
oil I just know that I wanted to make a
part back into the gossiped everyone you
are causing does I love it
it's like braid her hair inside so what
happened today Cindy well glad I decided
what didn't we do you know what I'm
talking some about that Jimmy Bly so I'm
talking to Stephanie the other day and I
only sell these askew tissue and by the
way I showed her she chose what the [ __ ]
was she thinking and do you play did you
want to get those frames because I told
you know what the other thing got to
ring it yeah I was [ __ ] you on bounce
around topic to prop it all day do not
gossip what they're all [ __ ]
you know there I go cross so much one of
the whole lines do I'm used to that [ __ ]
it's fantastic I was like nearly your
son you can't like oh I gotta do that ah
be softer as I hey Bobby you want to
talk no all right yeah [ __ ] up already
no I mean all I hear is - you know what
you might you know what if that's why I
like your system or hmm suck on that
[ __ ] anyways baby limits are dual size
baby would you guys like would you guys
all want to take a sort of class of
helping daughters yeah yeah I'm a troll
dismissal gonna [ __ ] off our breakup
imma make her look like a pirate and
[ __ ]
you don't even try I'm going to try to
do some next-level [ __ ] I'm like check
it out you could either be a basic girl
or you can be a tiger today which one do
you have yeah you definitely need this
platter be like tiger that one girl
shoes is going to go to school or the
prom like looking like a [ __ ] tiger
your daughter is going to be a loser
neighbors lesson oh yeah your daughter
paper clips we're going to have no
friends there will be the top of the
town yeah indeed you will we're a paper
clip that'll raise no basic [ __ ]
you're going to be wearing no shoes
you're gonna have [ __ ] crusty ass
hair because she's like I'm not going to
waste this water even if I can have a
pirate patch [ __ ] bevor daddy put
with [ __ ] makeup
yeah I would not mind having a daughter
I would like to have a daughter because
sometimes you know we have a daughter
like the wife goes like Oh girls night
out just me and the dog we're going to
leave oh my go go ahead I wish I was in
closed beta they leave in like I'll
judge it off I believe judge over wings
oh I get the [ __ ] out of here
god damn it I mean is this pretty cool
though because I'm just picturing if I
was a single dad like I wouldn't know
where the [ __ ] to start like how the
hell would I like do her hair you know
look upon YouTube it is a ton of oh yeah
now that we have users it's not like she
landed in your lap at the age of 15 you
know that's what happened to Jeff she
landed in she landed on her dad's lap at
the age of like 12 or something oh and
then it was like okay daddy gotta be
mommy - oh [ __ ] I just got this
cancer you can either still do it keep
on talking go ahead so if this happened
to me and then let's say like I don't
even got like four year old baby girl I
got like thirteen year old girl with
problems their lives in a minute yo
there we go you know you feel a little
rusty you're not pulling a lot of cool
because views are moving
I can't even do no saying go you know
compete to take something you know
where'd you learn how to do that how big
Casey appreciates you enough I know some
pretty bad I can't do the ham y'all
think the story's a fake call you
[ __ ] [ __ ] sanjouji yeah y'all
stupid us out so anyways I learned how
to do this
no altima to because my friend Leslie
she has really long pretty hair and I
was bored as [ __ ] and I was like oh man
how I braid your hair she like did my
hair all day and I kept looking kicked
out of class that's one picture they
kept operating girl's hair is that fast
I don't know how to braid it like that
yeah I told God I know you keep it and I
wasn't pretty enough I'll be doing it
was fast
yeah when people have the different
multi-coloured thing and it's just one
strap I thought that was so cool because
they would go to these trips to like
Cabo or like Mexico and then they would
get onion like that and they come back
and I'm like they didn't wash their hair
and they have it done I always wanted
that corner old hair is [ __ ] hard
though man I should difficult I could
not do it absolutely and I really like
and you have the fast it's tight and you
have till I get the line really clean -
it's going to come out all [ __ ] up
so you there's an actual skill to it
that's why you got to pay the lady up on
the block while you sit on the stoop but
she does it for about 20 bucks well Jay
can use fans I hope you guys liked that
video once again remember if you want to
be involved just submit some article
than while suck your dick now but
seriously though there's more videos up
there
[Music]